human interpersonal touch is crucial
it's social glue i think we
underestimate
how important touch actually is in our
social interaction
human touch is key to our survival it's
in our dna
touch is deeply under researched
they're probably a hundred papers on
vision
for everyone on touch we tend to take
touch for granted touch relies
literally on the whole of our skin it's
the organ
of touch but what happens when we touch
other people
and why is that special touching other
people
is processed by the brain with different
mechanisms
we discovered very late only in the
1990s that in humans
we have a specialized set of cells in
the skin
which then travel with specialized
pathways
to particular parts of the brain and
this system is called the sea tactile
system
[Music]
the hand strokes of parting the fur
sends this signal to the brain saying
you're in close physical contact with
your best friend here and what that does
in the brain is trigger the endorphin
system
we feel very relaxed and particularly
important trusting
in the person we're doing this activity
with and that creates this
sense of friendship
light slow stroking at exactly two and a
half centimeters a second
this is the caress that we are hardwired
to like
[Music]
it's comforting
what happens here then so the cuddle
sessions take place
at one of the pots cuddle therapy
involves
hugs stroking squeezies all sort of
forms of platonic touch
it's a very simple practice yet it can
actually have rather powerful effects on
people
it can stabilize their heart rate it can
improve
their weight gain and some studies for
low birth weight babies
even suggest that the time they stay in
hospital can be reduced
if they have lots of touch stimulation
is really forming the first part of
social bonding
which is why i say if you really want to
know how somebody feels about you
don't listen to what they tell you just
feel how they touch you
[Music]
if we have a situation where we're not
able to touch the people in
our daily lives that we normally touch
it's not like everything's going to fall
apart
instantly but our
feelings of connection of empathy of
trust
will slowly degrade anybody who i care
about
you get a hug so my biggest struggle was
not being able to hug my mum
to wash her hair to do all the things
that we do bonding
painting nails and do her feet for her
that one broke my heart still when i
think about it i could cry
if you deprive an animal of touch the
animals become
literally sick both in the mind they
develop a lot of anxiety
and also they live less and they're less
healthy in the long term
[Music]
the whole social concept of touch is
really
changing in are kind of learning society
to touch it does feel a little bit like
that
which is sad when people during lockdown
were exposed to films where there was
natural touch people had to jump they
were started talking to the divino you
can't do that so that's a good sign of
how quickly we learn to inhibit
ourselves
i don't think you'll see people
interacting in the same way that we did
before the pandemic i find it very
unlikely
that we would ever lose the sense of
importance of time
you should never say never when it comes
to evolution but it will all depend on
whether
other forms of behavior that allow
us to trigger the endorphin system in
the brain
to create friendships really
start to work better or more efficiently
than physical touch and i suspect that's
unlikely unless we give up all notion of
having
romantic relationships
i think the future should be hugs all
day
[Laughter]
all day every day
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already
hit the subscribe button and click the
bell to get a notification each time we
upload a new video